Speaker 1: OK, let's let's see who else we can
talk to here real quick. How about how about
Colin from Oregon. Colin, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, can you hear me OK? Yes,
I can. Mr. Pakman, it's good to talk to you
again. Pleasure education, if that's OK. OK,
listening to this this long conversations with
everybody, I'm concerned. What do you think
American education needs to do to stop things
like people buying into conspiracy theories,
people absorbing lies? What does the
education system need to do to adjust
our strategy? Because we're kind of we're kind
of too late now. We're going to have to do some
backpedaling a little bit. But what can we do?
Speaker 1: Yes, how do we it depends on different
there's different problems with different
solutions. There are some school districts,
Texas is famous for this, where the curriculum is
just insanely politically biased. And it leads to
people who come out of school prone to all sorts
of disastrous beliefs because the curriculum is
biased. That's one problem. And the solution there
is one. On the other hand, there's lots of school
districts where, first of all, the curriculum
is just not rigorous enough, in particular when
it comes to people understanding how to think for
themselves. And so introducing critical thinking,
media literacy and probably philosophy classes
pretty early, I would say probably sixth
or seventh grade, if not earlier, that would be
important and potentially a solution. And then
third, there are parts of the country and parts of
culture and society where education itself is seen
as liberal indoctrination. And so no matter what
it is that is in the curriculum, if that's your
belief going in, you're going to resist it. And
that's going to also lead to ignorance. And people
like you say that buy into stuff. So there's a
lot of different problems and the solutions are
not exactly the same for all of the problems.
Speaker 4: It's really unfortunate because I'm
a teacher and I'm really just caught in the
middle of all of this mask on mask stuff,
you know, short of Florida governor saying you
can't wear masks and then my governor saying you
have to. And I live in an area where everyone is
up in arms and everyone thinks the freedoms are
being. And I'm just dude, I just I want to teach
my kids right now to be better than this. Right.
Speaker 1: Right. No, I can't even imagine
how difficult that is. And unfortunately,
you're a cog in the wheel in the sense. Right.
So you can all you can do is the best possible
job with the kids sitting in front of you.
Speaker 4: I your your guest, Mr. Cousins,
said that there was a memo that
came out about Donald Trump,
Junior said, comparing educators to the
Taliban. And what do I look like? Mr. Flagman,
I appreciate you. Thank you for your time today.
Speaker 1: Thank you. I appreciate it. I hear the
frustration in your voice. They're all right.
Thanks to everybody who called in. That's going
to do it for today. We will take calls again
very soon. And I hope to hear from you then.